hello and welcome to this video playing
swap the national master Miller yeah
this is I don't have a good score and
some like plus two and now we meet with
me being on my all-time high rating I
can I can try something else then check
this is a sideline against the car wash
but quite an annoying one because black
is sitting there against the bishop app
it has to defend the whole game we'll
see ya I don't know much more I think
this is usually played let f5 between
this Bishop c5 this is not an issue
yeah it's a completely symmetrical porn
structure and black should not be in a
big problem and a big trouble but it's
kind of unattractive to play of course
against the bishop pair bit surprised
that he allows this here k 95's maybe 95
maybe it just goes Bishop a 6-pin and
try to defend to this position yep so i
can trade or i can try to keep a little
bit more on the board i think i'll try
to keep that bishop rook da Dagobah
should reform in taking what's possible
but this seems to be a little bit more
interesting yeah I only have a slide
plus go against him but he never has a
better rating than like 2,200 usually so
I don't really do well against him okay
so he's um giving me this pawn question
is
okay i can take and take a seven
actually right there is nothing nothing
to be sad against this pawn wrap I
believe
okay if I take the phone now he will
take e 4 but why exactly cannot take
busy because C 200k 92
okay so let's do it like this then it's
two pawns after all hey Bishop f5 as
possible i think i can also taught 8b
seven but this is good it's just a pin
black resign yeah it's in two points
okay I was important win you know it
like I would like three points for that
game with this high rating and lose a
million environment if I don't win so
this is an interesting line against the
Trojans d take c5 it's a very fast way
of playing yeah black the problem is
black does not really have a good
alternative here he can try to play
something sharp like this but in this
particular case I think III is good and
that is not a convincing continuation
and so Bishop takes check yeah and now
Josh you get to this get to this ending
which is very one-sided of course air
black um it's not a big trouble as I
mentioned you the game which is quite
unattractive not sure about night f5
this looks like it helps me a little bit
yeah of course this is a debatable
decision I can also take and play this
him and packages like black g form and
term I'm certainly a bit better because
of the porn but it's not it's all a big
deal okay I thought that this is more
interesting and yeah he cut into some
trouble now fly playing this but I think
it just it just gives the pawn and five
ticks and now he has to take on e4 this
was the way to try to defend
the question is if I should take here
actually because he has this and checked
well certainly I can try to win here
with the extra point it will be
difficult task probably a an
unsuccessful task so i will probably go
back and play this which is a pawn and
the slide weakness but it's also
opposite colored bishops but this is
what he has to do after this i'm
basically winning them okay there was a
good win and a new all-time every point
helps thanks for watching